another favorite squared square well is
this one I face favorite because this
one was actually found before the
Trinity students found theirs they were
scooped they was just before them and
the and this was published first last so
disappointing so if I'm being technical
this was the first squared squared found
but there's no theory behind it this is
some point it was some fluke Yahweh's
made it's made out of squared rectangles
actually those previous squared
rectangles that been found there's
copies of those in there he's put them
together and scaled them up and scale
them down
there's no Maps in that it didn't help
you find more telling no theory about it
but it was the first it's that is so
annoying as well here's one more square
and this this one I like because it's
more aesthetically pleasing notice the
squares are more round about the same
size so instead of having a squared
square where you have one tiny square
one massive square with a lot of them
seem to look like that this one's more
balanced the squares are round about the
same size if you take the ratio of the
biggest to the smallest this has the
kindest ratio right this is the more
favorable ratio because I don't know sir
maybe it's got a nice square square it's
the smallest ratio between the biggest -
like James and I squared yeah I like to
think so
one thing is tempting to do with these
squared squares is turn them into
puzzles because you can cut them up and
then say can you make them into a square
or something like that
this is actually a rectangle it's a
rectangle that I've made out of the
smaller squares I must find the complete
set I think some of the smaller ones are
still in here having this be 100 there
you go so it's like a jigsaw I can you
put these together like a jigsaw and so
that's what one of the Trinity students
did he actually this is the one he
turned into a puzzle and he gave it to
his mom and he said well I know what the
solution is but can you find it and so
she tried to find a solution and it
turned out that she found a different
solution
using the same squares no so there are
two ways to use the same squares to make
the rectangle of the same dimension as
well for the same dimension and a star
nice nice those --sold item s so they
are two rectangles the same dimension
using the same squares but in a
different order okay I'm going to say it
this was built uh CH training in maps
built at was given problems at Bletchley
Park because they knew he liked puzzles
he knew he was a kind of a guy who liked
to do a problem a puzzle and he gave him
problems that they thought can be solved
and I thought we've given up on this so
he's oh yeah you go and do it and so he
worked away and people were kind of
looking over going is he actually doing
anything because he doesn't seem to be
doing anything but he was and he sold
these massively important problems that
helped us break codes in World War two
he was doing that yeah and you can
randomly choose any of these things you
have to have a quick look at it oh my
goodness this is his original book or
I'll it noted like it's a notebook yep
so if you just open that up this is like
mathematics Christmas morning I think I
think if the Royal Society was on fire
which I hope never happens this would be
one of the things I would grab